and tell us a bit more about the vigil
and the march today
well president zielinski the president
of ukraine a few days ago
called for people across the globe to
take to the streets in solidarity
to show their support for ukraine to
show their support for the people of
ukraine and to show their support for
freedom so we're doing that but also we
condemn
putin's barbaric aggression and we know
the people of ukraine will see these
images we want them to know that in
their darkest hour they're not alone
and sadiq of course london is a melting
pot for different cultures um
will you be supporting a ukrainian
family we know the transport secretary
grant shaps and says he'll be working
through the motions to welcome a
ukrainian family
well full of admiration for everyone
who's opening their homes to ukrainian
refugees we personally won't be for a
variety of reasons at least protection
security and lack of space but in london
we've seen over the last few uh weeks
london has gone above and beyond not
just donating money to brilliant
charities but also by opening their
homes to those arriving and i've been
incredibly proud at the actions of
londoners over the last few days and
weeks and what's clear is we're sending
a message loud and clear that refugees
are welcome here
and many british families saying that
they're frustrated
by the scheme to try to bring ukrainian
families here to the uk to london
they're saying that it's full of red
tape we heard from a woman earlier today
on sky news and breakfast so she was
close to tears with the frustration
around the difficulties what do you
think about the
response from the government in allowing
families to come here
in relation to this issue
the governments have been appalling
we've been lobbying them for weeks now
uh to do what other countries in
mainland europe have done to make it far
far more easier
for those people fleeing for their lives
refugees to be able to come to london
there's a disconnect between the
generosity shown by londoners and brits
across the country and the actions of
our government the complex visa forms
they're delayed their red tape makes it
really hard i spoke yesterday to a
londoner who finally
after four weeks has been able to open
his home to a ukrainian it shouldn't be
that hard i speak on a regular basis to
leaders in germany in france in italy in
spain and poland and when i compare and
contrast we as a country have done from
our government versus those i'm
embarrassed
pretty patel the home secretary will say
though that there are
reasons to have these security checks
not least for example um if it was a
russian spy that was perhaps trying to
take in a family um so there are those
security checks they say that need to be
in place what would you say to the home
secretary
of course we're going to have security
checks but you don't need a long long
questionnaires many many pages of forms
to fill in
to reassure
prince patel that they're not a danger
to the safety of our country the reality
is
more than three million ukrainians have
left
ukraine the reality is many tens of
thousands have been given a safe haven
in cities in germany france italy spain
who also have security concerns so why
are we different it's really important
that it's far easier for those refugees
fleeing ukraine asylum seekers and
refugees to be given a safe haven in
london we know we've got a good track
record as a city in providing a safe
haven for those fleeing whether it's
afghanistan whether it's syria and now
ukraine but it's really important the
government makes it far far easier
otherwise the ukrainians will be left
with the impression we really are
creating a hostile environment we're
better than that